from screen junky studios in the Heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie fights now your host Andy signor
greetings screen junkies and welcome to
Monday Mania here on movie fights this
is going to be epic I'm actually very I
have no idea what's GNA happen here I
don't have a favorite in my head it's
anybody's game three strong
competitors well it's going to be it's
going to be interesting any three of
these can take it so welcome to the show
we have some awesome topics today
including will Jesse Eisenberg be a good
Lex Luthor we finally saw him bald so we
thought it's a good topic to talk about
him as Lex Luthor uh Mission imposs
trailer dropped uh uh we also have uh
Mission possible versus The Fast and the
Furious best action franchise I wonder
where Nick will stand on that one as
well as best movie cameo in honor of the
Entourage movie and their amazing list
of cameos at the end uh so tons of fun
stuff as always don't forget if you
don't like a fight don't skip it well
don't leave you can skip it and go to
the next fight by clicking pick your
fight on the bottom right corner on
YouTube uh and you'll have plenty more
options and see all the stuff we're
doing and as always the last trailer uh
the last uh fight is a cue for this
week's honest trailer and this one's a
fun one so stay tuned you'll want you
want to hear what that is all right now
this is Monday Mania I want to thank
let's cut we have a special graphic made
just for this this occasion thanks to
erow wave our Finland uh friend our our
fan in Finland Ira the Monday Mania
graphic do we have that oh my God look
at that guys that is that is awes made
for you three Kudos Ira wow fantastic we
will link you in Twitter I look like an
anime bad guy Alicia's got a real snarl
you guys the Red Fury was showing so
this is You' inspired the fans this is
epic this is a big day let's meet our
Fighters today's Fighters are Nick Mundy
screen junkies resident fixer three wins
three losses Alicia Malo co-host of
profiles and AMC rewi two wins one loss
Roger bar founder of IM mockery one win
four
losses four losses yep oh wow and let's
not forget on The Dan cam to keep you
all fact checked and uh proper it's Dan
Merl how's it going guys it's going well
Dan I'm going to be fighting one of
these three that's right you are let's
explain that yeah the winner of this
round will take on Spencer against Dan
and it'll be a fantastic Brawl for the
ages it won't be next week we will tell
you about next week's show at the end of
today's episode uh but get ready because
the winner of today we'll go for that
belt and finally we may Crown a new
Champion oh no no Dan are you feeling
nervous yes yeah you should be this is
this has been a tough bracket he's been
flop sweating for six weeks before we
get to the show I just want to remind
everybody if you're a lot of people have
been asking we have a new iTunes feed
new RSS feed please make sure you click
the description on YouTube yoube you'll
find the new one please go subscribe
rate and comment if you've already done
it Go comment again go rate again if you
haven't done it yet please go make sure
you subscribe and support us there
because we're doing really well on
iTunes and we want to keep the show
going so please thank you for your
support all right let's start this fight
in the great words of so many amazing
people now let's do this this is where
we
fight fight
fight wow round
one so we got our first look at Jesse
Eisenberg officially as Lex Luther with
the bald head they've been hiding it we
know he's been doing it but it just
brings up uh the Fantastic thing we
should fantastic point that we should
just bring up which is fight number one
Ben zeer on Twitter asked what do we
think of Jesse as Lex do we think Jesse
Eisenberg will be make a good Lex Luther
now I know we don't have footage we're
basing it not just on the footage but
Jesse Eisenberg in general do we think
he will make a good Lex Luther and we're
going to start with you Alicia I'm
really excited to see Jesse Eisenberg as
Lex Luther from what we've seen so far
which is just that picture he does look
menacing he does look mean Zack Snyder
has talked briefly about the character
saying that this is going to be unlike
any other Lex we've seen on screen so
forget Jean Hackman forget Kevin spacy
forget any ideas of a Heisenberg sort of
inspired Lex Luther this will be
something different completely I think
they'll update him for modern times and
he'll be someone that is different to
the Marvel villains in that he won't be
physically imposing but he will be
extremely intelligent and able to pull
the strings maybe behind the scenes now
Jesse Eisenberg you never said it was
going to be good though a great no you
never said it was be it Jesse Eisenberg
is a fantastic actor and this is why I
think he could make a really great Lex
Luthor because we've seen him play this
kind of dichotomy of characters before
Zack Snyder said that this Lex Luther is
going to be a different person publicly
than he is in his private life and if
you want to look at Jesse Eisenberg not
being the bumbly awkward guy that we've
seen before you just need to look at the
Double the double was a brilliant film
where he played two sides of the one
character one was bumbling awkward the
other charismatic cool confident a
little bit evil we also saw him be
genius with A Touch of Evil in The
Social Network and also be charismatic
Like a Villain needs to be in Now You
See Me So all that combined makes me
really really excited to see Jesse
Eisenberg take on Lex Luther Nick has
been laughing at you but Nick please
calm keep it yourself you'll get your
turn Roger bar VI mockery what do you
think man good good choice or bad choice
I I do not like uh him as as Lex Luther
uh first off uh we we know what he's
going to be like he's going to be the
same neurotic character he's always been
in just like the social network uh uh
the guy's never really displayed that
much in terms of acting range I'm sorry
he hasn't like yeah oh he can play kind
of cool and and kind of awkward and
stuff it's always the same thing just
like we saw him in Zombie Land and stuff
he's gonna be that same neurotic kind of
guy he'll have a little bit more evil
going behind him and all but that's
about it what's worse though is he
doesn't look the age of Lex Luther that
is my biggest problem with it Henry
Caville and Jesse Eisenberg are the
exact same age they're 31 years old yet
Henry looks like he's 40 and Jesse looks
like he's a teenager and now with his
head shaved he looks like a teenager in
chemotherapy I'm sorry but that does not
work for me it just it doesn't work uh
and we really can't go off of a black
and white image to like know exactly
what Lex Luther's going to look like
completely with the suit or whatever
he's doing but I mean we basically we
know he's going to look like Jesse
Eisenberg with a shaved head and that's
just I'm sorry he he has not proved
himself and I would much rather see
somebody else perform uh the role of Lex
Luthor uh and he just he cannot hold the
candle to Jee Hackman's performance uh
or Kevin spy and I'm fine with them
taking Lex Luther in a different
direction but I mean Jean Hackman come
on that is that is the uh that he set
the bar as far as lexther goes very uh
disparaging words yeah Nick what where's
your stance uh I don't I hate this to
the my very core but I'm going to agree
with Roger to a lot of it just it
sickens me but here we are in this world
uh Superman is a fantastic being uh
Powers he's like a messiah character he
is the person to save Humanity for a to
be a compelling villain you need the
opposite of Superman you need someone
with enough Charisma enough guile enough
wit enough just like brilliant
personality to be able to convince
people hey you know that guy saving you
you know the guy stopping floods you
know the guy reversing time he's a dick
because I'm really good at convincing
people with my personality and my
magnetism I can't talk um that like you
know that he's wrong and that's got to
be like that's the best Lu Luther I
don't care about age I don't care about
how he looks he just needs a Magnetic
Personality and I'm sorry but Eisenberg
while he's great at playing The Walking
hoodie that's what he does in every
movie you brought up the double they put
sunglass gles on him and clothes that
actually fit and that was the big change
he still wasn't likeable and in the
magic movie they couldn't even make they
couldn't even make him look charismatic
in the magic movie you know he was like
the worst part of that you know that
should have been Woody Harrelson's movie
it should have been Woody harelson in
this movie that would have been a much
better person he's much more charismatic
much more uh brilliant I mean you know
there's plenty of people to do it I get
that he might fit this movie like the
Eisenberg uh like the Zuckerberg like
quiet kind of guy but like men Miss Ing
and it's probably going to fit this
movie that doesn't make it good like
that doesn't make it good he needs to
have something to draw people away from
the guy flying in the blue and red cape
to be able to draw people in and I don't
think Eisenberg has that in him
whatsoever just look at his face there
is nothing menacing about it there's
nothing that threat he's looking right
down the camera and he doesn't look like
theing awkward guy at all he's menacing
and like no one went to prom with me now
everyone's going to pay which is Lex
Luther he's an outsider and he'll be
getting out for revenge and he's the
opposite to Superman so he's someone who
can be the genius he should be Evil
Genius behind the scenes but would but
he needs to be a politician and he needs
to be able to get people to gravitate to
him and I think he's able to pull the
strings you just killed the poster you
just killed the poster a I didn't mean
to do that that was not her fault that's
that's quity that that poster Falling
Down is about as much damage as I could
see Eisenberg ever doing no the damage
the real villains these days are the
villains behind a computer and he could
pull that off completely if that's the
direction they going behind a computer
is that going to be an exciting hackers
vers Superman I mean he could I'd rather
watch hackers change perspective of the
people of metropolis quite easily yes so
I'm listening there's a great back and
forth but yeah tell me more about how do
you think the Envision how do you
envision him playing against I think
they will go for a modern villain and
they'll go for a modern villain who is
someone like a politician like you said
he can be charismatic I disagree with
you I think he can be completely
charismatic and really sweet and then
someone you wouldn't assume and then
behind the scenes he can be quite evil
he's also got those smarts so I think
they'll use that and behind the scenes
he'll be tapping away I'm just imagining
this that he'll be changing the
perspective of the people of metropolis
turning them what's he going to do doc
Superman like just get in the computer
and just start hacking his like Bank of
America profile account cuz I like
that's I I see them doing that in the
movie I think you're right I think
that's what they're going to do in the
movie I don't think that's good though
and I I just don't see him charismatic
thing I don't see where you're getting
that from he just does not have that he
is like a little weasly guy behind the
scenes and he's fantastic at that he's
actually really fantastic but that is
not Lex Luther and if you want to know
who double he's fairly chartic I think
we the biggest missed opportunity with
this movie is in the casting of Lex
Luther I think they should have cast
Clancy Brown Clancy Brown you want
someone that people know about and not
like like you want someone that like
okay if you're going to actually recast
now there's some fight between you I had
to bring it to all right well look
Clancy Brown has played Lex Luther
longer than anybody has played Lex
Luther he's been doing the Animated
Series voice he has an incredibly
intense stare he's got these Cold Steel
blue eyes that just Pierce through you
he's got that deep Barone voice and that
is why he is continued to be Lex Luthor
and you want someone who's like who's
like menacing large intimidating he's
6'3 this is a guy we've already seen be
intimidating with a shaved head if you
remember in the Highlander that guy no
one remembers the Highlander besides us
two and he was great in it but like
here's my yes Clancy Brown sha Shang
come on there's a lot of we know who
Clancy Brown is
hopefully I need to see where your
arguments are differing because you're
agreeing a lot of things except for
Clancy Brown versus Woody harelson uh
but tell me help me separate I know
where she stands I need to understand
where you two are separating your
debates or are you teaming up where are
we that is that possibility that Roger
and Nick would team up I I hate to say
it but I'm I'm trying oh no feels so
wrong it feels so wrong I hate this so I
hate audience doesn't always like it but
this is where we stand they will both
win points if they get it you will uh
not expect it okay sh don't Ru it though
so let so give me your last point and
then we're going Lea uh reply
absolutely it's it's not about how he
looks it's not about his age it's about
being the opposite like you said of
Superman the guy sitting behind the
computer drinking like nine Monster
drinks like energy drinks is not the
opposite the opposite
is the most human person as human like
the best human to go against Superman
and the best human is someone who's like
charismatic and and handsome and someone
who can like like he's attracted and
almost like a heartthrob and someone
like people gravitate to because he's
got to draw get the people that
gravitate from Superman to him and he's
got to be the ultimate human I think and
and and Humanity often is evil so I
think that's what I think Lex Luther
absolutely needs to be and we also want
to let Luther we're going to let Nick
have it I don't want for Alicia's
fairness now let thoughts on that you
give us some examples how is he
charismatic how are they wrong well I
charismatic yeah charismatic in the
double for sure when he plays the flip
side to his normal character and that
was a great uh reflection on the two
sides of Jesse Eisenberg the people that
people that don't think that he can do
that with the movie he Pro that he could
because he was a ladies man but I think
Nick you're agreeing with me in a lot of
things you're saying he is perfect for
this movie he fits into this world he is
the opposite to Superman and that's why
he'll make a great Lex Luther in this he
fit into Silicon Valley on HBO he
doesn't fit into Superman it fits into
this world that's that doesn't mean it's
good that doesn't that doesn't make it
good because it's still perfect for the
movie that doesn't make it good because
this like it's still a mixed bag whether
this movie will be good based on the
previous movie so while it might fit I
don't think that necessarily makes it a
good right that's something we do
disagree on I don't think it fits again
I I say the age difference is very uh
jar Ing and I I just do not see him
working for this he said they're the
same age they're the same age visually
they're not they are not they're
opposite he could be Henry cavil's kid
and I would not be surprised except for
you know he's do all right I got to make
a rolling here everyone's got their
their piece in Dan anything you're
cleaning up here before I do that no
it's actually it's a clean round clean
rounds good job we we fought fair this
is tough because I think you all made
very valid points but I'm going
to I think the the argument that I
didn't I didn't see enough of why I mean
to me the thing that sort of sealed it
was the neurotic character that we know
and love I didn't see enough of really
selling me how he's done that
differently so for that reason alone I'm
giving it to you two all
right I don't want it yeah friendship
over okay okay all right uh I do want to
go to otisburg though I hope we get to
go to otisburg in this new movie all
right otisburg Jesse Eisenberg prove
these fellas wrong I look forward to it
let I hope he does I hope he does that
would be wonderful round
two um we got our first look this week
at Mission Impossible Rogue Nation lots
of cool stuff in the trailer he was
hanging off a plane I was pretty
impressed did were we all impressed we
asked no there wasn't really an argument
there because we were all like we like
the trailer so we weren't going to fight
about why we like the trailer um uh we
all agreed so we didn't make that our
fight here so our our fight actually
became a separate topic which is about
Tom Cruz who's in that movie and I think
looks great doing a good job and that's
types of movies he does but it begs this
question is Tom Cruz a great actor or is
he a popular just a popular movie star
that just makes good movie star movies
do we we don't we understand the
difference of what that question is
movie star versus great actor um which
one is he and this time we're gonna be
starting with you Roger um I think he is
a popular movie star uh I would not say
Tom Cruz is a great actor great is a
very strong word that's something I I
reserve like for Daniel de Lewis that is
a great actor that is a guy who can just
transform himself SN himself into any
role and he is a different person every
time you see him but Tom Cruz he's he's
he's a good actor he he's but generally
the same guy we see in most movies like
he's shown some range and some stuff uh
but like in U eyes wide shut you know he
he did good in that movie but Nicole
Kidman stole the show I think we can
agree with that I mean even if even if
you didn't even if you didn't like ories
yeah well there's a lot that social but
Tom Cruz was definitely kind of at the
bottom of list that's a pull Draco sorry
and kubri can pull amaz he he was able
to pull some amazing performances out of
just about anybody but Tom Cruz it was
Tom Cruz in that movie um oh okay yeah
uh that's so you'll come back you'll
fight more Nick where do you stand on
this okay Tom Cruz is a movie star and
not only that he is the best movie star
ever and that's not a bad thing it's
great that he's a movie star because we
need more movie stars movie stars get
asses in seats and he's also he's also a
great actor because and he he wouldn't
be doing be as prolific if he wasn't if
he was a sham he wouldn't be doing
everything but he's a great movie star
he's been gracing our screen for 30
years in a variety of performances and
he can get audiences to see different
types of movies that they wouldn't have
seen with anyone else because he's that
charismatic he's that good and he's just
the best and frankly we need Tom Cruz we
need Tom Cruz to keep making movies
because there's aren't there aren't any
movie stars left there's like three
There's Tom Cruz there's the Rock and
Pratt kind of Downey but like we need
movies like movie stars is not a bad
word I think it's a great word he's the
best at it and he's so are you saying
both no I'm saying he's a movie star so
you don't think he's a great actor said
great actor though because you did say
yeah no I I think he gives Great
Performances like but I'm going to go
with when I think of Tom Cruz I think of
movie star and the best movie star ever
and we need that wow is this a team of
again Alicia where do you stand great
actor or popular movie star Tom cures is
a great actor and people forget that
because he's a popular movie star but he
is a great actor he's a three-time Oscar
nominee he's worked with some of the
most brilliant directors around Martin
scolesi Paul Thomas Anderson Stanley
kuri Oliver Stone and he is able to pull
off a great variety of roles just look
at born on the 4th of July where he
starts out the movie with a clear eye
patriotic you know teen from small town
and then he changes into this really
bitter wheelchair bound Vietnam vet
angry at the world you look at Magnolia
where he plays this cocky guy and then
by the end he's crying by his father's
bedside you look at collateral he
managed to convince you that Tom Cruz
the hero was a villain and talking about
chilling looks when he said oh the
bullets in the fall killed him look you
really believed that he also was great
as a coward in edge of tomorrow but
people forget that he's such a good
actor because he sells movies so well
and I agree with you that he we need Tom
Cruz because Tom Cruz sells movies he
makes people want to see it he makes
people believe in whatever unbelievable
World he's taking them into because of
his commitment no one commits to
no agreed and I think being a movie star
is even more important than being a
quote a great actor because there are
plenty of great actors but unfortunately
for this industry to survive we need
movie stars to make money for movies and
then people can go to it and that's why
he is the best movie star ever and we
need him to do that like if he was like
he can take like an indie type movie and
then make it a blockbuster like all the
movies you just said and that's what
makes him I don't think he he really
does have that kind of range though that
you're you're talking about you know you
mentioned Magnolia and stuff he did the
same thing basically in Vanilla Sky I
mean that's not that not that big of a
stretch and stuff I'm just saying you
know cocky at first and then all sad at
the end I mean yeah no I think range are
there other examples of him showing
range in your head uh like uh Jerry
Maguire and Rainman Rainman he had to
play against Dustin Hoffman he had to be
a great supporting actor to support that
brilliant performance and I think that
Tom Cruz
his commitment to the role I mean no one
takes a movie more seriously than Tom
Cruz I think he's the flip side to
Daniel de Lewis in that he doesn't do an
anchor complete physical transformation
an here's what I wanted to say at the
beginning is I'm I'm not like a huge fan
of the guy's acting like I don't think
he's some amazing actor because the
question is is he a great actor and I
would say no but I am a fan of the guy
as far as his action movies he I'm not
sure he he's someone like bringing you
into movies that you wouldn't
necessarily see like uh absolutely wait
no listen listen listen Edge of Tomorrow
Minority Report collateral I would see
those movies with or without Tom Cruz I
just would I mean those are interesting
stories I love sci-fi I love action
that's good stuff but you know what the
rest of the country isn't aren't big
sci-fi guys they're not big movie nerds
they're going to go because of Tom Cruz
and Tom Cruz gets people to see movies
how many more people saw Vanilla Sky
because Tom Cruz was on the poster then
they never I know if that's a good thing
or you know or collateral or this is
great I give me me one quick line
because I think I've I've i' this is a
pretty easy round for me based on
everything that's saying but final
thoughts quickly I don't I make sure you
got everything you out you wanted to say
um Tom Cruz he's someone who's never
really blown my mind in terms of his
acting but the action scenes he is in
those are what's mind-blowing it's the
action movies and he's he's 52 years old
and he's willing to throw himself out
there and do all these stunts that's
awesome I like that about him Nick the
best movie star ever and you have to be
a great actor to be a great movie star
commitment is makes a great actor and he
is a great actor because he completely
commits and he chooses to do more fun
roles because he loves the audience to
experience this kind of popcorn ride
with him but he has the range and he's
shown that many times yeah I don't think
uh I think uh it really became down to
ride Alicia because you kind of picked
both and didn't really head your bet so
I that's why I'm rolling Nick out and I
think Rogers being a little unfair
because I think Born on the fourth of
July alone showed range in just that
what she brings up from he changes his
character drastically in that movie
great dramatic great actor Daniel de Lou
people like that a
great for decades so I think Alicia
sealed that one easily Alicia gets the
point well thought well thought Tropic
Thunder yeah that was a pretty amazing
range in well he's good but anyway he's
got a good sense of humor I love have
done stuff together yeah all right uh
speaking of Mission Impossible on the
trailer uh next week uh is Fury 7 which
is a big huge franchise so what is this
five mission Impossibles and this will
be the seventh fur Furious 7 with your
best friend The Rock who you're uh we
should tease this you're going to be
speaking with the rock on this week's
screen junkies right yeah you're not
sing you're actually speaking to him we
do a lot more than speaking yeah they do
I think you play Truth or Dare with the
rock it's going to be good wow as well
as meeting the other cast members yeah
that went less well did you did you play
spin the bottle with him no you will
have to tune in on Thursday find out th
Nick did uh following his wrestling
debut this week which was fantastically
hilarious good job Nick uh we somehow
how I don't sorry how we got to send
house somewhere but you got WD in the
fury 7 so you're doing great Nick but
thanks for embarrassing us both times um
so but back to the the topic at hand
fight number three what is the better Mo
modern action franchise Mission
Impossible or the Fast and the Furious
now five movies versus seven we haven't
some of you may not have seen the fifth
one or the seventh one yet we're going
to base up until fast six and two Ghost
Protocol is what we're basing these on
obviously uh and we're starting with you
Nick which is the best action franchise
Fast and Furious or Mission imposs this
one's actually really tough because I
love both franchises uh they both like
push the boundaries in film making and
laws of gravity they're both they both
have great movies they both have a
couple not great movies um the thing
about the franchise for me and and
franchise is the key word not to get all
hard off on everyone um was the The Fast
and Furious every movie yeah what are
you pick no it's fast and the furious
with Fast and the Furious surprised I
wasn't sure the movies build off each
other there's a story there's a
mythology what happens in one event
leads to changes what happens in uh the
sixth one or the seventh one and there's
a story and the characters grow and the
characters change and they all build off
each other the mission of Possible
movies while great almost reset after
each movie it's like they're just a
collection of Tom Cruz action movies
where Ving RSA shows up occasionally you
know they're great but I don't feel like
they're a franchise I mean we don't know
what happen like what happened to all
the characters that happened before Tom
Cruz's character the the one part that
mission possible doesn't have is Ethan
Hunt hasn't really had any character
growth whatsoever in the movies like we
still don't know why he's doing it while
he's willing to jump off you know hang
off on on a plane we we're glad he does
but we don't know why and there's just
no development between one to another
what happens in one doesn't affect what
happens in the other and I think that's
what makes a strong franchise a strong
Saga and and Fast and Furious has it and
I look forward to you sharing those
examples of how they do that in Fast and
Furious we come back to you but in
meanwhile Alicia where do you stand
Mission Impossible is the better action
franchise it's just it's got better
crafted movies better directors better
actors uh better storylines better plots
and it gives it gives great directors a
lot of money to do some really exciting
stuff some exciting set pieces and they
feel real because you know that Tom Cruz
is actually doing them I I agree that
fast and furious is fun to watch but
when you watch those stunts these days
it's like I don't believe it because I
know that they're going to walk away
without a scratch and and they're not
actually doing that CGI no they they are
doing this they are doing this fire
building through playing through three
bu three buildings yes watch behind the
scenes they're doing it they're
literally jumping out of planes there's
some things that don't make sense but
anyway well no I'm not saying it makes
sense but yeah Tom Curry is on the side
of a building in Mission Impossible 4
was really scary seeing that on IMAX uh
the first one Brian deparma took a big
risk where he killed the squad in the
first half hour kind of like a psycho
twist second one okay John Woo it is
motorbikes and flowing hair but that's
one movie that's been bad out of the
four and the fifth looks really good
number three JJ Abrams gave him a chance
to step out of the TV world it was a
modern almost a born style action
thriller and it had a great villain
played by Philip Seymour Hoffman and
then number four Brad Bird stepped out
from The Animation Studios showed what
he could do those action sequences were
great plus we got more of a chance to
know more about the squad the one looks
great cuz what happened to krid what
happened to Tanny Newton what happened
to Paula Patton well I think that who is
Ethan Hunt mission impossible has done a
better job at uh at building the
franchise whereas Fast and Furious they
made up for it but they had to work damn
hard to fix all those plot holes they're
not plot holes they were they were CRS
there are no plot holes in fast than the
Furious let's let Roger his opinion up
before we do the Dan you can have fun
with that cuz I don't have that much
time uh go ahead Roger where do you
stand uh Mission Impossible hands down
no no doubt about it uh with Fast and
Furious you always know what you're
going to get uh because you know it's
like what crazy situation can we put a
car into all right great as opposed to
what crazy situation we can CR well
let's let's they they're not so limited
with Just Cars and Stuff in these in
these Mission Impossible movies it's all
Spy technology you have explosive
implants in people's heads you have
masks that replicates a person's look uh
you have have they done that before
you have gloves that let you climb like
Spider-Man let me have my My Moment here
Nick all right uh and uh look uh so you
know Tom Cruz he climbed down and ran
down the mirrored exteria of the Burge
calafia in uh it's it's the tallest
building in the world in Dubai and what
happens in the next fast the fous movie
they wanted to take the cars to Dubai
but they found out that there was a tax
break by going to uh let's see what was
the name of it uh Al Abu Dhabi uh just
south of Dubai so they went there for a
tax so they're just riding on the coiles
of the ideas of Mission Impossible which
I don't like and talking about stunts
yeah they're doing stunts in uh in Fast
and the Furious but guess what it's not
the rock doing the stunts it's The
Rock's stunt man named tanoi Reed he is
the guy doing it he is the guy doing the
stunts there's there's your badass Rock
no Tom Cruz is the one doing the actual
stunts in his movies there you go I
think we should teame out br
okay uh so tell me which one of the
movies in uh Mission Impossible where is
are we going to respond to that rock
shot in the footage there's behind the
scen footage all you can do is ignore it
and you know it no there's footage of
him just slamming STM through a glass
table and they're picking glass out I
don't have to explain like they do the
they're jumping out of a all right him
slamming Stam through a a table is that
as dangerous as Tom Cruz dangling from
the tallest building in the world or or
I can go to Six Flags and watch stun
show like easy but like I'm talking
about the best movie I'm you're talking
about one of your biggest stars in the
movie willing to take that risk and
putting the stunt guys aside and say no
I'm going to do this and I'm tired of
seeing the same movie over and over
again where Tom Cruz is uh getting
hunted by his own IMF team the IMF gets
disbanded and then they have to beat the
bad guy Ro absolutely dwarfs Tom Cruz
and you're and he can't do the stunts
himself I I
exactly I rest my case I just I don't
think they're Fran I don't think it's a
the franchise I think it's the same
movie over and over again repeating with
just with a different hot girl in it and
with different hair fast and furious is
so ridiculous soon they're going they
but there's a story there is a story I I
challenge you to explain me the story of
her 7 okay off camera so no spoilers but
ah it was so confusing it made no sense
it's just like chucking everyone in and
we've already established that not only
are they stealing from Mission
Impossible where they're going yeah I I
I wouldn't take what Alicia said
actually cuz I a fan of both franch but
can you tell me the mythology story as
well as the names of the girls that have
been in there that are no longer there
anymore that's what one
two cuz if you can I will be incredibly
impressed 1 2 3 five 6 4 7 I will put
Too Fast Too Furious is better than
Mission Impossible 2 it's really
confusing oh but I think Mission
Impossible 2 had a misstep but not as
many I think there's nothing worse than
drift that's a good movie I'll watch
that movie Mission imposs when they're
like fighting with uh Doug Ray Scott is
just hey I'm not going to challenge you
that Mission Impossible 2 is terrible
but I'm going to say it's one rare
misstep from the franchise where it's a
huge misstep had that almost canceled
Paramount uh uh also Mission Impossible
doesn't have these like crazy requisite
TNA shots of the women in their movie
what are you talking about it's the same
thing they do the watch The Fast and the
Furious trailer you are looking up
someone's crotch that's a
Michael Bay move I'm sorry for the
language but that's have seeny uh thy
Newton in Mission possible 2 when uh it
was like and every trailer for a Fast
and the Furious movie shows am I allowed
to explain
thethy yeah exactly a nice dress rather
than girls in bikinis or super mini
skirts right up against the car they
really do it in 17 Dan did you have
something to add in here very very
quickly because I want to go back to
watching this um the correct order for
FES your is 1 2 4 five six 3 S it's that
confusing it's not that confusing it's
really they did three an off shoot and
then they realized let's conect that in
at end speaking of movies connecting to
each other you saying the mission
impossible ones the next mission
impossible picks up right where the
current where ghost prot left off
they've already said that so there is a
continuing story line plus we're seeing
they just started after three after four
movies they're just starting a story
line through it because I still have no
idea who Ethan Hunt is do you also
speaking else thank you what happened to
his wife he's a spy his wife is still
alive where is she feel free to
challenge him back on the other I look
look look I I feel like look it's here's
where we stand I one last thought let me
get one last uh statement from every but
I think it's hard being on the one
person it's not easy it they they
haven't officially teamed up no they did
say they did team up did you team want
to Roger went I don't know Roger didn't
commit Are you standing on your own or
you teaming up Roger just like all the
guys in my life are not able to commit I
don't know uh you know what I I'm going
to play it risky I'm I'm going to
playing his own SOA give me your piece
here I know where you stand I think uh
the mission impossible it's it's better
better written better cast better
directors better actors great action
sequences still as exciting as fast and
furious plus it has it has further to
grow I think fast and furious has to
keep topping itself every time by Fast
and Furious 8 they're going to literally
be jumping sharks like they're going to
be jumping cars over sharks he's hanging
off a plane he was hanging off a
building they build the movie about
though but I agree that's silly I feel
like Mission Impossible does the exact
same thing you just said except there's
actually a story line with it rather
than restart Mission Impossible has the
like the benefit of like hey we don't
have to worry about anything that
happened before let's just create a new
movie we'll get Tom Cruz with a
different haircut bring Ving RS back if
we can and then we'll just do a whole
new movie and not worry about anything
that ever happened before that's Nick's
closing Roger you're closing in fast in
the furious eight they're probably going
to have someone hijacking a space
shuttle and they'll duct tape a car to
it as it goes into space and yeah that's
very funny that's funny and Goofy and
ridiculous and and ridiculous but look
uh we've already seen all what mission
impossible does it introduces they do
the same thing over and over again will
you let me speak yes all right listen
we're we're talking about like uh all
this crazy technology uh that gets
introduced in every Mission impost movie
and that's always exciting what with
fast the Furious all right they're going
to throw a tank into a car chaseing big
whoop uh we've seen that kind of crazy
stuff in their movies already great
they're going to introduce new cars but
with with these uh with with the Tom
Cruz movies it's it's amazing it's all
new technology and we even we're talking
about him uh you know latching onto the
side of a plane we're also seeing him
actually uh diving into a giant water
sphincter in this trailer there's a
giant water sphincter and he dives into
it I'm on board because I just want to
know why is Tom Cruz diving into a water
spinter is it looks I don't know what is
like Tom Cruz is diving into goatsy on
that on that I want to see that move see
my thing I think all right you had your
pieces you all said your pieces the
thing that won me out really uh was was
two lines uh but it was really the the
your The Rock call out of the stunt
double was a great blow as well as the
fact that I love that you pointed out
that FES totally just took the Dubai
moment from Ghost Protocol like oh let's
put a car in it instead of to it was
more than that that was a great point I
got to give it so Roger ends up winning
for those two those debates alone good
job Roger so now Roger takes the lead
because you all have a point but Roger
now has two points wow round four Nick I
mean I I wanted you to have a little bit
more this the story in Furious 7 I'm
yeah no it's it's great there's anyway
there's no story in the mission that's
all you kep counting on you got because
that's that what makes a franchise Dan
has Dan some thoughts well if uh if Vin
Diesel Vin Diesel is is correct then
Nick will have the last laugh because
he's predicted that Fury 7 will win best
this year's so that could put that could
that'd be a big blow to Nick's side so
we'll see I don't I've seen the movie
it's very fun I don't see that coming
though I don't think it'll be best
picture uh round four Uh Kevin Smith is
getting the entire cast back together
for M rats 2 because Kevin Smith just
has to keep doing the old stuff that
everyone loves uh looks like he's
getting everyone back he tweeted with
Shannon Dy and he's getting the whole
gang back together oh Shannon dy's
nothing to do how did how I don't know
uh but that brought up a very good
question for fight number four what
movie cast would you like to see
reunited for a sequel they're doing this
so often now but what's one that would
actually be one we'd be excited about
let's start with you Alicia what do you
think I would love to say the cast of
The Breakfast Club reunite for a sequel
so I was just at South by Southwest and
got to see a 30th Anniversary screening
of the film it was a packed House people
loved that movie still there's a lot of
love for it and now the people that grew
up with it are now all parents' age or
you know that they're older they can
relate to the movie in a different way
they had Molly ringal and Ali Sheidy
there did a Q&A and they were talking
about how their perspective on the movie
changed with age Molly said she used to
really relate to the teenagers now that
she's a parent she relates to the
parents and you realize that the
Breakfast Club is all told through the
kids perspective like are the parents
really that mean or is that just how
they see them so I would love for the
cast to get back together when they're
all older they're all parents age and
now we see their perspective on the
movie I mean maybe you could do
something crazy like they all have kids
and then they all together detention and
so you could have the the two story
lines happening together the younger
crowd for a younger audience and then
the nostalgic factor of seeing all these
guys back together and they could hang
out for the day and you could see where
they ended up did any of them get
married what happened on Monday morning
were they still friends or did they
ignore each other are they still the
same stere stereotypes as they were
before or have they changed I want to
know so much and that's why I would love
to see this cast back together for a
sequel fascinating Choice Roger what do
you like to see um well first off I I
don't think the Breakfast Club is what
do you like to see oh we can't argue yet
no get your point fine uh uh I would
like to see The Fifth Element I want to
see the cast of The Fifth Element back
um uh Mila jojic uh Bruce Willis Chris
Tucker uh Tommy tiny liser Zeus from uh
no holds Bard yeah uh Gary Oldman uh The
Works uh I think it was a absolutely
fantastic sci-fi Space Opera and it
there's just no movie out there like it
there is nothing out there that has ever
been made like it and I'd love to
revisit that world and the director
himself has said he'd like to be go back
to that Universe at some time maybe it's
some of the same characters maybe it's
other characters in that world but they
created something absolutely unique
something totally memorable and that is
something well worth revisiting in my
opinion Nick what's your pick and then
we'll start the fight all right uh I
liked what Alicia said but I want to do
the fun version that's why I want to
reunite the cast of Goonies I want to
see them uh Goonies was the ultimate uh
kids wish fulfillment movie where like
kids that looked like kids talk like
kids went on this crazy adventure now
becoming an adult be vaguely um you know
getting older I want to see these guys
come back and in the become the ultimate
adult wish fulfillment movie and them
going on an adventure and did you say
movie Wrong twice yes sorry I'm sorry
you just you just said move me moely
yeah I keep going sorry feelings he
still think first hard second one fair
enough no I just think it would be
taking everything she said and seeing
The Goonies come back as adults deal
with adult crap but also going on this
adventure that pushes them like when
they were Fearless as kids now like like
can you do the same thing again and like
you know question your Humanity question
your manhood and all of that coming back
together and seeing this gang back
together data chunk uh mouth yeah I want
to see Cory Feldman back in a movie uh
everyone Brent I I want to see everyone
back and just have this great really fun
adventure you bring the kids to and I
think that would be great like them
getting another like crazy adventure
would be the most fun in the world like
great three fun ideas now let's start
the fight go ahead well you're not going
to bring back sloth because he he passed
away he passed away sloth is and that
and I don't want to learn that sloth
died I want to learn that him and chunk
like lived happily ever after and nunies
was did SLO die yes yeah he's that's
what the actor get another actor in well
that's what sets him off in the
adventure that's what brings everyone
together sloth funeral they to take off
his Superman shirt he has a treasure map
that's what sets him off his Adventure
thank you Roger the big problem with
buried treasure yeah oh now they buried
instead of left we kid played by me this
is all great look both of these movies
that they're pitching rely heavily on
nostalgia
and you know that's that's great and all
but that's not necessarily going to draw
in audiences whereas The Fifth Element
you're actually going to bring a lot of
people in just because they want to see
an awesome space Sci-Fi Action Movie
you're introducing all these amazing
things people would actually to be fair
though we're not teing up but people
sending he asked twice go ahead Alicia
say it now with with I heard I heard
Jupiter she said Jupiter sending
ascending yeah that doesn't mean it's
going to be as bad as Jupiter ascending
or anything think but it's going to get
people into theaters with amazing
costumes amazing characters story Alicia
go ahead go ahead I was going to say
something like Jupiter sending shows
that didn't get people into Cinemas I
love Fifth Element but I love that it's
a standalone film I don't need to see
any more of that because that is a great
movie that still holds up so you could
watch it in its entirety the same could
be said for all three of these movies
they're all great movies
that but you know these these two movies
have a definitive ending and you can
just leave them there you don't need to
go beyond that you know with the fifth
elment you can ABS there's this whole
universe that they're working with not
kids in high school getting older and
now they're reflecting back on their I'm
not think understand to me I love
Nostalgia they're all it's yours is
Nostalgia too for like hard sci-fi nerds
I mean it's just it's all Nostalgia I
mean my movie though the difference
between my movie and your movie because
I think we have a lot of same things
mine would still be fun and not
crippling depressing because I think
most of those characters half of them
would be dead no no half of okay they'll
better at the end maybe one of them
couple of them are dead out their
funeral they're at Old Molly ringwald's
funeral you know who would die first no
probably not Claire would not die they
don't get back together and John Hughes
himself was working on sequels to and
that's another reason I don't want to
touch it because John he he might even
have stuff that's already unproduced
because he he wrote a lot of screenplays
before his death and he was such a great
writer I'd venture to say he's a better
writer than think he wrote a Breakfast
Club 2 scripto no he wanted to his
family won't even let an Uncle Buck TV
shows in 2005 him and amilio Estes were
talking seriously about doing his family
is trying to stop the Uncle Buck TV show
remake I don't think they're going to
make you can't have Uncle Buck they're
they're not going to tr The Breakfast
Club C is still alive and still together
well you know what without John Candy
right also so all right I need to hear a
little bit more each of you go ahead and
knock the other two down okay well The
Breakfast Club with my idea you could
bring in a new audience by having a new
Young cast and not doing a remake and
you could also bring in the older crowd
who love that movie and have that
nostalgia
whereas I think The Goonies you you're
relying so heavily on the audience who
loved it I don't think people young
people would want to see an older
Goonies no well like you bring in the
kids too I mean you go on this great
adventure this great family adventure
when was last time we had a great family
PG-13 Adventure I mean I can't think of
anything quite often didn't the rock do
one called uh that wasn't good journey
center of the Earth or something no but
you get Richard Doner you get Steven
Spielberg you get Chris Columbus and
then you make the ultimate Feelgood
movie yes it's Nostalgia and Nostalgia
sometimes sucks but like you get The
Goonies back you get their kids back you
go on sloth pirate Adventure that was
tattooed on his chest as an as olda I
think seems really sad I don't want I
don't want to see oh your movie it's a
breakfast club that movie was sad
already like most of the people are
they're going to be popping pills
they're going to be talking about their
cutting children and how miserable their
lives are that's what their lives are I
don't even see another movie about five
people sitting in a locker room now that
they're old hating their life Breakfast
Club was but I don't have time for that
I want to see a mad what about Fifth
Element Fifth Element was I never cared
about Fifth Element I just never I never
like it was fine all right I don't want
to I don't i' would rather see all those
people make another movie Roger go ahead
knock the other two down both of these
movies they are they're movies that have
kids in them kids are the stars and that
is what people remember I don't want to
see them grown up and old and reflecting
back on everything if I want to see uh
adults acting like kids and going on
childish Adventures or doing ridiculous
things I'll watch Wet Hot American
Summer that's fun for me I like that
kind of stuff but with the Fifth Element
age isn't going to matter it's not going
to matter story what's the story okay uh
lelu and Corbin Dallas are meeting
against the they're fighting against the
six element which is a new evil in the
galaxy and they have to have a they're
having a kid together and the kid is the
only one with the power to actually stop
it Corin and Liu can't do it you have
kids in the movie I'm introducing kids
rather than making kids grow up they're
having to protect them from all angles
coming at them all kinds of foes and
everything that's wonderful that's going
to be a movie that can put people in
seats Dan has a thought here go ahead
fact check us please I just wanted to
resp reply to your request yes the W
said in 2005 that John Hughes had talked
to him about a sequel to The Breakfast
UHF at that time it was you know they're
obviously a little younger he sick then
or something well let's John hughes's La
last movies weren't that great I mean he
started going downhill like with Dutch
and what was it Beethoven's uh third or
I forget the the later movies that he
did John Hughes was on top of the world
in the AG he was amazing and stuff but
yeah you know who's still good Spielberg
Richard Donner I mean I just think I've
always wondered what happened to the
characters for The Breakfast Club I've
never Wonder Facebook check your
Facebook page they're miserable they're
posting on Facebook about the kids that
they don't won't talk to them oh talking
about miserable you just said you want
Cory Feldman to come back what are you
talking about have you seen that guy's
life right now it's awesome all right so
I got to make a calling here I feel like
you all got your points out and this is
tough I think uh I think Nick did did
Nick had a pretty good shot down on you
Alicia for it would be a really
depressing movie most likely of those
characters old hating their lives
cutting children Etc necessarily so I
like regardless whether true or not it
was a good knockdown but I think uh so
I'm debating between you two um
interesting thing but I I I guess I I
gotta for the sake of being able to
clock them out a little bit easier than
I feel like you clocked him out I'm
going to give it to Nick Nick you set up
most of my argument it was and I think
he did you guys were but then he said
it's the funner version which it would
be the funner version I think is a fair
point he made although I like Doc and
depressing movies fair enough go ahead D
round five wonder you lik Alex Luther
Dan you have something you wanted to add
yeah just very quickly because Nick is
always harping on Richard Donner he
hasn't directed a movie in like 10 years
he's still good and his last one was 16
blocks and thenine and the lethal weapon
four before that perfect and I'm just
saying his last good movie was like 20
years ago 16 blocks is really good uh so
let's go down to round five the trailer
for the new film Maggie came out this
week and it features Arnold
Schwarzenegger in a more dramatic role
he's getting older and I think he's
dealing with zombies in this movie uh he
can't do action movies forever so that
brings up number five here could you see
Arnold Schwarzenegger as a dramatic
actor uh and we're gonna start with you
Roger do you think Arnold could pull off
uh doing something strong I think it's
going to be hard to take Arnold
Schwarzenegger seriously because uh it's
it's Arnold Schwarzenegger you see his
face and you you're just waiting for him
to like say some ridiculously corny line
or pull off some impossible feet of
strength that you know obviously he can
no longer do that these days um but
Arnold's also had a career in comedy and
uh I think he could do more comedic
films I mean he's done uh you know I
mean if you want to talk about him doing
dramatic roles Mr Freeze in Batman and
Robin that's basically as dramatic of a
character as he's portrayed you know his
his wife has you know this terminal
illness and all that and God what a what
a mockery of the character that was uh
it's just abysmal and you can't help but
laugh at it it's comedic uh so him
taking on a dramatic role while I
understand why he would want to maybe do
that at this point in his career because
I mean he can't like lift giant trees on
his shoulder anymore or anything like
that I I'd rather see him do comedy than
uh drama because I cannot see him him
pulling it off nick uh some of you may
not know this but um Arnold
Schwarzenegger has won a Golden Globe
for in 199 1977 s for um uh it's called
stay hungry in a dramatic role and he
won that he's done you're right he's
done crap and he's doing tons of crap
now I love his crap yeah but if you get
him with the right writer right director
of course he can do a dramatic
performance and I think he we'd be good
at Sylvester Salone nailed out of the
park in like Cop Land so I think these
guys are talented he he's lazy and he
loves money but and so did schwarzeneger
he won he won uh in Stallone started as
a dramatic Octor so Schwarzenegger was
Hercules in New York I'm sorry he also
he also won a Golden Globe he won a
Golden Globe and I'm sorry but like you
get him in the right part you get him
the right of course he can be make a
dramatic part he might not do it all the
time but I think the reason why he sucks
is because he just it's easy for him
it's easy to get a paycheck people will
pay for that but he could do a
low-budget movie with the right person
get kathern Bigalow get James not a
classically trained actor man he's he's
not someone who's going to like pull off
a drama better than anyone anyone else
and he he just we're not comparing it to
anyone else we're comparing can he do a
dramatic performance and absolutely can
you can you look at him in a drama and
take him seriously I don't think you can
see all right Alicia let's see where you
stand before we open up the Reigns here
yeah I'm not convinced that he can be a
dramatic actor um and we don't want him
to be we want him to be the action guy
everyone can do an Arnold impression
mine
is you got what you want to give people
he has such a particular way of speaking
it's hard to take him seriously in a
dramatic role the trailer for Maggie
looks really intriguing but it's 2
minutes of other people speaking he has
one line in the trailer and that makes
me a little bit worried he does do a
concerned look very well but I'm just
not convinced that he can pull off a
dramatic role he's done it before
Predator Terminator Terminator 2 and
days did you say Predator is a drama he
wasn't cracking jokes everyone else was
but I'm talking about a Nuance okay and
you know what I don't want funny
swartzenegger because it's like your
drunk uncle coming over and hanging out
with you and your friends I don't want
that I would rather him try something
different I would support every movie he
does where he's not like doing some type
of pun off an older movie cuz I hate
that that is awful well we did it was
called sabotage or something no it
sabotaged the prison movie see huh did
you see it yes cuz yeah cuz I'm that guy
was he good
no no because funny funny old post
Governor Schwarzenegger is terrible
because he's doing the same Schock he's
just trying toap say I'll be back again
of course that's why I want to see him
in dramatic parts and I think he could
comedy so much better I mean look at him
in like jingle question that's not the
question of course he could but he can
do a lot because he is an actor he is a
good actor he's a lazy actor who loves
money and loves crap and loves being in
movies that where people pay him to be
crap give him the chance he could do it
not a good I haven't seen stay hungry
but I wouldn't be using a Golden Globe
as a selling point if you've met the
Hollywood Foreign Press Association
they're more into having stars in their
in their ceremony right just
look history of awards there's been
plenty of like ridiculous Awards handed
I'm convinced and that's my I mean for
God's sakes crash won the award for best
pick so you don't think so let me let's
keep focusing I heard you Nick I get it
tell me a I'd love to hear your separate
opinions so I know who who I'm awarding
points if you win uh why uh why again is
it what is it about Arnold you think
that can't be pulled off like Nick's
saying with a great director a uh a good
performance as a dramatic actor I think
it comes down to the way he delivers
lines his accent his accent no not just
his accent but his acting when he
delivers the lines I think he's a great
physical performer but when it comes to
dialogue and making you really believe
his dialogue I don't buy him as a
dramatic actor if we're talking about a
dramatic nuanced performance other other
than Arnold's comedies uh he's not had a
lot of lines in any of his movies that's
why it's always just like these on
liners that he can say very quickly
without anything you know coming out of
it but comedies he can pull off that's
what we know but drama it's it's just
not something because we've grown up
with Arnold we are used to his crazy
facial expressions I mean look at Total
Recall him doing all that ridiculous
stuff when he's in the chair and
everything that is the Arnold we know
and that is the Arnold we love but as he
gets older and he can't do that that
doesn't mean he should take on drama he
can do comedy we've seen him do that
before that is what he should focus on
now since he acting is getting a little
bit I mean action is getting a little
bit beyond his his years uh drama though
we're going to just constantly be
distracted thinking about when's he
going to say some ridiculous line that
we're all going to laugh at and I
guarantee you once this movie comes out
and we've all seen it or maybe we
haven't all seen it uh we will be making
fun of some lines that he delivered in
this super dramatic role where it's
supposed to be something dark and
something going on with quickly no one
thought jeanclaude vanam could do a
dramatic role and no one still does
except have you seen jcvd where he did a
great performance give him the chance I
bet he can do it with that last blow I'm
giving it to Nick Mundy hey anything's
possible I guess and it it was hard to
distinguish which one I would pick out
of you two Nick gets it quick quickly
Dan quickly uh just a little background
on stay hungry he w a Golden Globe for
best uh debut and emotion picture he
played uh a bodybuilder who was Mr
Austria who was getting ready to win
real dramtic real right Su go stret
round six did you just say suckers yeah
this was a question we got from Twitter
that we just thought was interesting
it's a random one uh but Jeremy uh Beva
Beva Baka Baka Jeremy L Baka sorry if I
said your name wrong Jeremy uh he asked
what's the best American remake of a
foreign language film uh we're going to
start with you Nick great uh in 1991
there was a French film called Lali I
don't know how to pronounce it I can
barely pronounce English words um and it
is the precursor to 1994's Jame
Cameron's True Lies with Arnold
Schwarzenegger probably at the Apex of
both of their careers true Li I mean I
watched L tally last night it's fine
True Lies is awesome True Lies is one of
the best if not the best action movies
of the 9s it's it's hilarious it's gives
Great Performances Jamie Lee Curtis um
Tom Arnold Schwarzenegger Bill Paxton
Tia Carrera everyone is fantastic in
this movie it's one of my favorite
movies it is the best foreign remake of
all time Alicia what's your pick the
best foreign remake is The Departed the
film that finally won Martin scorsi the
best director Oscar and made over100
million domestically that is based on a
2002 Hong Kong film called infernal
Affairs and infernal Affairs is a
fantastic movie it's it's really
exciting and fun to watch so it's hard
to top but they did it and they did it
so well because they got a great
director they got a brilliant cast with
Matt Damon and Leo DiCaprio and Jack
Nicholson played such a great villain
they updated the time and the place to
be Boston and this was a return to form
a return to gangster form for Martin
scori it's a it's a great film that
stands apart from the Remake so if you
watch the Remake it's great I mean sorry
if you watch the original it's great if
you watch the remake of The Departed
then it's also great they're very
different though different Vibes so
that's why I think the Departed did
really well to make an American remake
that was actually good and also felt
like something original and fresh Roger
what's your pick uh my pick would be
David Fincher's uh version of The Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo
um wow the reactions of the panel here
did not do not favor that choice but
let's hear quickly go ahead I love it
when the panel is against me happens so
often um
uh this is this is a beautiful film it
is absolutely incredible uh right from
the get-go the opening credits uh you
have this it's like you're in uh Rooney
Mara's head uh with this beautiful
nightmar visuals of all the uh uh black
syrup just like being poured all over
the characters wonderful absolutely
wonderful they've updated this movie
from what was it I love the original uh
the the original versions believe me I
do but they they were very much more raw
and uh not as not as polished or
anything anything but David Fincher's
directing style combined with Trent
Reser's incredible soundtrack for this
uh that they they they used all these
organic wooden instruments and combine
them with electronics made the movie way
more chilling uh the casting could not
have been more perfect uh Rooney Mara
absolutely transformed herself for this
role she actually not only you know did
she you know shave her head and do all
this uh she she bleached her eyebrows
she got piercings all over her including
piercing her nipples just to get into
character for this role and that is the
kind of invest I love to see someone do
if they're going to take on you just
loveer nipples you don't think Tom
Arnold pierces nipples in true Les uh I
believe it I believe it I think he did
that before True Lies though uh thoughts
on the other two people's uh selection
series uh mine Nick will start us yeah
it's it's my round uh my film is the
only one that is actually better than
the original film I think we're talking
about best remake in general compar I
was best American remake of a foreign
language film yeah no and I'm saying my
film is actually superior to the
original whereas yours I would rather
watch the original I know but I'm just
saying it's the it's his argument but go
ahead and whether it's right or wrong
keep going quickly and I think it's also
the best out of all of these movies it's
the most fun it's the most action-packed
uh the part is the part is almost like a
parody of a scors Acy movie where Jack
Nicholson's accent and the part at the
end where they just keep spoiler alert
killing each other it was it was it was
kind of hilarious how like silly that
movie got like it just went off the
entire rail talking about true that is
about as silly as it gu True Lies is
True Lies was genuine in it I feel like
scor was sorry par and I'm sorry The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo killed that
franchise for an American remake it's
not good the first one was better it's
not that hard to Fincher absolutely
wants to make another one Rooney Maro
wants to make another one a lot of
people do a lot of people do they can't
make another one all right Alicia why
why do you feel like we'll get to you
why how was yours better than the other
two mine is the better film uh the best
film of the three it's it's a tense cat
and mouse game it is fun to watch at the
same time it's well written and has
great cast it's not silly I didn't see
it as silly I thought it was brilliant
and and it's an Oscar winning film plus
The Girl With Dragon Tattoo the Swedish
versions are much better okay all right
neither of you all all all you two guys
I'm I'm just pointing this out both of
you guys have just said the the girl
Dragon 2 is a bad movie but you have not
given me one reason why because it's
exactly the same as the Swedish version
think he also said that the fact that
Sony won't make another one is a reason
whether it's right or wrong it's the
same I mean I love David Fincher you can
see he is actually my favorite director
but I was disappointed by this film
because I saw the Swedish versions first
and then this was exactly the same but
not as good and I like Rooney Mara but
no me but repace she kicked off she was
awesome was awesome roone Mara Rooney
Mara took it to another level AB I watch
the version I watched the finer version
and I was like have you seen the yeah I
watched the fin version first and I was
like okay that was that was that was a
movie and then I watched why it was just
boring and and kind of like still really
stiled performances it was like watching
a British play and then when I watched
like I watched the original I was like
okay this isn't the movie I would always
watch but I got why people love this
movie and then I watched the other on I
think it's cuz it's such a dark movie
that's why you're off-put by it but I
I'm still not hearing Reasons from you
like why it's it's such a bad movie
you're just saying all right this is a
movie that's that's not any actual de
bad the acting sucked the like Fincher
was so did was giving so many uh like
excuse me jerk off shots comp just wor
about composition then oh it's
composition you're saying good okay
great Dan go ahead what were we gonna
say oh okay you're talking about True
Lies and you're talking about jerk off
shots come on no True Lies is Elizabeth
goes through some incredibly tough
things there's and there's a lot going
on in this movie for time sake I think
they both crushed you on that because I
think between them and the audiences and
the studio it sadly was not seen as a
great film I think it's fine but I think
they both have made a very clear and
strong argument that I don't disagree
with that remakes her fun so for for the
sake of this we're fighting True Lies
versus departed and I could let you have
the time but I think Alicia kind of
killed it and departed is a the best
film based on the awards the Accolade
the scorsis everything over fun very fun
true life so Alicia gets the
point good job now makes us Nick with
three Roger two Alicia two so Roger and
Alicia if one of you wins this round
seven Q round seven if one of you wins
this you will go into the speed round
against Nick if you don't we will do a
TI breaker I will go take all right so
the Honest Trailer this week uh is one
of last year's most talked about movies
um a polarizing film I'd say uh
audiences either loved or hated it uh
and it featured an uncredited Cameo from
a major star Midway through we won't
spoil what it is or what we're talking
about uh but that's a tease all the teas
you're getting this week uh so that toss
uh that in addition to the Entourage
trailer which listed a ton of cameos in
their movie uh that brought up the
question that Adam Ros on Twitter asked
what's the best movie Cameo uh in all
movies and Alicia we're starting with
you it's a good question best movie
Cameo has to be Tom Cruz and Tropic
Thunder as Les Grossman this happened in
2008 and at that time people didn't
really like Tom Cruz he did that crazy
Oprah jumping couch thing in 2005 he was
he was really intense about scientology
I'm not saying that their opinion on him
was right but I'm saying that people
were sick of him people didn't believe
that he could do anything fun and
exciting until he saw you saw him as Les
Grossman and it showed that he could let
loose I mean he is in a fat suit he's
dancing to ludicrous he is like this
Harvey Weinstein type spoof of a studio
exac and and so many uh fword and curse
words being thrown out there it was
nothing that you ever expected Tom Cruz
could do and when you saw it it was so
much fun so I think because it's
completely unexpected and it helped to
turn the time
on public opinion on him that's why Tom
Cruz in Tropic Thunder is the best movie
Cameo Roger what's your pick uh I would
have to go with Bill Murray in Zombie
Land uh this is I mean uh I I I guess I
can't say it on the show but Bill Ethan
Murray uh that that has basically become
a meme at this point uh people at that
is the one thing people remember from
Zombie Land more than anything Woody
harelson and uh uh uh you know
Tallahassee I should say uh they show up
at at Bill Murray's house after the
zombie apocalypse when they think
everyone is dead but who is one of the
few people left alive in the world it's
Bill effing Murray and I mean honestly
that's that's one of the few people I
wish would be alive in the world if
something like that happened he's such a
fun guy and he he gives us so much in
this Cameo it's not just like a little
oh hi I'm Bill muray and walks off the
screen or something he actually he's
dressed as a zombie and we learned this
funny story about him he's dressed as a
zombie so he can go play golf and that
seems like something that Bill Murray
would actually do in real life if there
was a zombie apocalypse and he also has
fun with Ghostbusters we've all wanted
to see like more Ghostbusters with Bill
Murray but he never actually signed on
to do a third movie because obviously
there weren't any good scripts or
anything and he thought it might be a
cash hog or something but he does a
Ghostbusters vacuum scene with them and
we absolutely love it he's just it's
like him having fun with the fans like
he would in real life this is a guy who
shows up at random parties all around
the world just randomly just for the fun
of because he's a normal guy two great
cameos Nick what's your third uh Bob
Barker and Happy Gilmore uh this is a
scene that came out of nowhere Bob
Barker was the pric is right guy no one
thought this would ever happen and then
the next thing you know he kicks the
out of Adam Sandler for six seven
minutes and this not only redefined who
Bob Barker is when he retired in Price
is Right they showed the entire thing
this made his career but it also made
Adam Sandler's career and we know that
went to like you know for the last
10 years but for 10 years this is the
movie This is the scene that made Adam
Sandler that gave us some pretty damn
great comedies up until about 2004 and
and while your cameo was great and
actually don't think yours was a cameo I
think it was just a part in a movie cuz
he was in it for like 35 minutes this
this Cameo uh not redefined one career
and then created another and I think
that's why it's the most important Cameo
the best Cameo out of the three I would
say that I saw Happy Gilmore when I was
young in Australia and I had no idea who
he was then you did afterwards you did
afterwards I had no idea that's not your
fault we don't get pric we have our own
prices right host in Australia so I was
in the movie it he wasn't in the movie
so I think that that Cameo wasn't
unexpected it wasn't a surprise to
International audiences who didn't know
that person but yeah I mean part of my
argument was that Tom Cruz's role in
that Mo I mean he's in it throughout
they're constantly calling him back and
stuff because you know he's like the
part in a movie rtics here Dan we do are
we calling are we defining that role as
a cameo they call it we we discussed it
and we decided to include it as a cameo
because we thought that the Bas
the basic surprise of a cameo is someone
that you didn't expect to be in the
movie
show was in the TR he was in the Trae
that out we we for her sake and we
called it it is a cameo so aside from
that let's hear what else you have to
say Okay um the other thing I love about
uh Bill Murray's Cameo is that they
actually they end it they they don't
have to like drag it out or anything
like that they have him get shot because
he was playing a prank on somebody which
again is something I could totally see
happen
but his death is even hilarious uh uh uh
Emma Stone she cracks up as he's
breathing like and she just bursts out
into laugh and she's like he just he
just gets me every time and it's true
that's that's what he do here's what
because we're run and we actually are
tight on time today sadly I apologize
everyone hates when I try and Rush this
along but I'm going to help us speed
this around I'm I'm G to Ru two two
pictures two people here who I think are
continuing on this fight sadly it's not
Bob Barker I think these two were
stronger surprise cameos that made a
bigger impact Bob Barker was funny so
Nick you're out we're focusing on these
two I want to have one last fight if
you'd like to chime in you're allowed uh
because you will help to find that if
you decide to pick one but that's sort
of unfair so I'm not actually not we'd
have a three-way battle I'd love to hear
quickly why yours was more you know
iconic what made it the best movie Cameo
obviously versus the other quickly and
uh go ahead Alicia you can start we just
said we defining Cameo by surprise and
there was nothing more surprising than
seeing Tom Cruz in this role Bill Murray
he was great I love that that part of
Zombie Land but it's Bill Murray it's
it's what we expect from Bill Murray
it's what we know of Bill Murray it's
what I like of Bill Murray I would never
have thought Tom Cruz would have done
half the stuff he did in Tropic Thunder
Roger final thought I never expected to
see Bill Murray pop up in a zombie movie
get shot and then do a self during his
death he actually not being very subtle
over there Nick no both are great no
that was both are great during his death
he's even self-deprecating when they ask
him do you have any regrets he he says
Garfield maybe and that I love it that
killed me and that killed everybody and
if you stay after the credits he even
says AAR gopher a little nod to one of
his older films it's just it's perfect
it's everything we've ever loved about
Bill Murray popping up out of nowhere in
this crazy zombie movie and it just ends
perfectly those are both hard I don't
EnV you this probably one of the hardest
ones of the show I will be fair because
it also defines who's going the speedr
so I'm taking this very seriously based
on the arguments is what I'm doing
because you both did a great job I
think I think someone just had one last
line there that sold me a little harder
than the other where it was he was Bill
Murray whereas I think there was
something about Tom Cruz that was so
unexpected you're like he's saying the
FW over and over again and doing B Apple
Bottom Jeans like you would have never
any I remember people in I like that's
Tom CW what they were so as much as I
love them both I'm gonna give it to
Alicia they just barely off of her last
thing that was very strong that was
fantastic really tough that was really
hard this whole thing been really hard
Roger Kudos high five you you are
fantastic I'm sorry very close that puts
Alicia and Nick with three points each
into our speed round we are going to get
right to it are you guys nervous Dan for
what for what it's worth I still want to
battle you not even for the belt just in
a regular it's going to happen we after
our Championship we will we will make
some fights where Dan can fight some
more cuz Dan be Dan's on that couch too
much uh I agree so speed round you guys
understand again how this works yes I'm
going to ask a question first answer if
you both say the same thing is what will
end up winning if you both say different
answers you will have a moment to defend
your answer everyone follow any
questions before we do this and you're
not allow no pulling a Hal rudnik as
they call it now or you're unclear after
it's been happen no okay that's mean
sorry
me okay these two movies are both
playing at the same time on cable which
do you watch the RoboCop remake or the
psycho remake
make I heard Alicia first Alicia gets
the
point this is I know we should get
buzzers don't tell us cuz then they're
going to yell at us that we don't have
buzzers we should have buzzers we should
have buzzers worse
villain Arnold Schwarzenegger's Mr
Freeze or Jamie Fox's Electro Mr freze
Jamie Fox Electro let's hear why Mr
Freeze okay Mr Freeze was so laughable I
never once bought him as a villain his
on liners were ridiculous and and he
made that movie which was really bad
even even worse whereas Electro I I
didn't mind him I liked the Jamie Fox
character the dichotomy of the two he's
a great actor Jamie Fox was so terrible
in that movie it wasn't fun at least Mr
Freeze was fun those puns were fun you
could out of that train wreck of a
Batman and Robin movie you can at at
least be like well Arnold Schwarzenegger
was having the most fun in the world I
would rather much watch Arnold sports
Ander Nick I'm gonna give you the point
based on that argument he was fun we
still uh take him to the coola we still
do
it chill out nerd face was not great all
right we're still
tied discounting the
movies who would win in a fight alien or
predator
predator predator beep quickly beep you
got to answer we got to answer alien
okay she's answering alien uh Nick why
predator predator is the ultimate Hunter
he's defeated any enemy that stood in
his way he can kill anything he is the
universe's ultimate Champion he could
kill anything kill Jedi he could kill
alien alien's just a bug alien is just a
bug Predator is a warrior he is a
Warrior Man Alicia oh um she agrees with
me um alien is I don't know how I'm
going to do this I'm going to suck
Alicia loses yeah I was going to say
predit this dud D got to be confident
got to be confident in the answers nick
nick one in the confidence cuted myself
I have completely peed myself ready
number three or four I'm sorry that was
three wow so this is yep number four
best movie with Jack Black in it hi
Fidelity are you allowed to answer
before Oh best movie with Jack Black in
it oh sorry I thought you were going
this or that that's the question quickly
uh
Bernie High Fidelity versus Bernie go
ahead Nick High Fidelity it was the
introduction of Jack Black what we all
loved about him it was a movie about
relationships music going into your 20s
it's just a beautiful uh wonderful
hilarious film it's one of the most
underrated hilarious films of the 2000s
Bernie showed that Jack Black could
really act he has dramatic acting chops
I was I was interested in the character
it was really charismatic character even
though he was so so creepy and he was
doing something i' hadd never seen him
do before that's why I choose Bernie I
need a little bit more assistance and I
need your last one quick line each on
why the other movie wasn't better Nick
quickly
Bernie was pretty
boring Bernie was a really interesting
character study where his High Fidelity
was fun but I'd seen Jack Black doing
that before I wasn't that excited at
least you got it based on that argument
point at the end I would have said
natural Libre for the S I was waiting
for like this or that okay this is it
the winner of this speedrun wins
wow best Hollywood James G James
Woods why gandini James gandini made um
he created one of the he was part of one
of the best shows ever he gave family to
the mobster you saw his sensitivity to
it he's a great actor his whole body of
work is awesome and he made chubby dudes
hot so uh James gandini is the best
James of all Cinema history I thought of
James Woods because I was just
rewatching video Drome and I was
remembering just how awesome he's had
what what a career he's had where he's
played so many different characters he's
had such a long career and he's done
such different things that I I think
he's such a great actor and a really
underrated actor b d is awesome I need
one more because this is this is for the
this is for the belt fight I need one
more sentence and it needs to knock the
other one down WEA this time starting go
ahead okay I feel mean saying this but I
feel like James gambini does the same
thing in all his roles he was the one
guy from The Sopranos and uh Woods has
had a long and very varied career James
Woods has done only James wood stuff
gandalin has just pushed the boundaries
of anything and James gandalin has that
one piece of acting with The Sopranos
that defined his career what has James
Woods done that defined his career
besides video Drome I love video Dr wow
this is a tough one why why couldn't
someone have just said James Dean it
would have been so easy well the music
stopped it's that
dramatic wow we out of time and I got to
make a winner based on those arguments
I think someone said that one roll to
find him so strong that it's James
gandal is to soo and I think Nick pulled
itely that was so tough that was really
tough I got a kiss I I got a I got a big
wow that was that was exciting all right
Nick Nick pulled through I I didn't I
didn't think he was gonna he didn't so
it's Nick and Spencer against you Dan
next uh or next episode it's not next
week a little housekeeping please don't
cut to that angle uh I'm excited to
announce that next week we will have
some fans in the audience watching a
special episode uh very it's going to be
very special special guests uh fighting
in the round but we've uh as you know we
had a call out to fans at home who'd
want to come watch an episode that's
going to be next week and I'm happy to
announce a lot of you submitted we're so
grateful that you submitted but I'm
happy to announce the winners here they
are ma from Hoboken New Jersey you're
coming to the show in the in Brian
Chambers from Niagara Falls New York
you're coming to the
couch and Mr Anthony Tony tubes from
Redfield South Dakota you are coming to
the couch we're flying all three of
these fans down we are so excited to
have them we are so grateful to all of
you I'm sorry we we wanted to bring you
all down so there's so many amazing
tapes that we got so thank you everybody
for submitting uh please uh please
please please thank you keep all the
support coming but uh for ma Brian and
Anthony we are so excited to have you on
the show next week to watch I'm sure
you'll do something slight or be
involved but uh we're very happy to have
you here it's going to be a very fun
show uh so thank you very much I want to
thank our panelist also Alicia Malone uh
give us your Twitter at Alicia Malone
correct yeah don't send me hate mail
please oh why would you do that these
people are amazing this is the hardest
I've ever done these people deserve it
they're going to send me the hate mail
I'm sure for not ruling you at the end
uh but Alicia Malone thank you so much
you are welcome back anytime you
fantastic I love doing this Roger bar at
imockery at.com anything else you'd like
to plug uh yeah I'm on Twitter i m o c k
r y come follow me on there talk to me I
love hearing from you guys uh # otisburg
and for any of you uh who are conspiracy
theorists about this show notice that
everyone who already had an icon in the
bracket and is a screen junkies employee
is now in the finals it's like the NCA
I'm starting up someone's a loser
I'm starting up on YouTube
someone's
aerology rology Lea's being
grateful and Nick Mundy atck Mundy on
Twitter yeah thank you you guys are
amazing you guys deserve it uh I mean
you should be here too uh check out this
week's screen junkie check out next
week's screen junkies WWF this week
screen last this week WWE and I hang out
the rock next week and then April 13th
my Comedy Central show comes out uh on
Comedy central.com check that out please
yeah return
to nothing to report my brain's gone
it's called nothing to report make sure
we tweet and tell you about that coming
up thank you everybody on Dan cam at
Merl Dan Mr Dan Merl anything you'd like
to send you thought Marvel Civil War was
intense you wait for a screen junkie
Civil War in two weeks I'm taking you
down he spent all the day hey Dan I
already laid the groundwork I destroyed
Fast and the Furious today so that's my
victory please follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at Andy signor I love hearing
from you guys and telling me what I'm
right or wrong and what do you want to
see on the show we can't do without you
guys so thank you much uh that's it we
will see you next week with our special
show and then in two weeks the belt is
on the line Mr Merl start training thank
you everybody have wonderful weekend
thanks
guys every podcast we put on YouTube
comes with this Kick-Ass graphic listing
all the topics your favorite screen
junkies podcasters are talking about if
you click the topics you can skip around
and choose your own podcast Battle
Royale go ahead try them all if you
haven't already subscribe to screen
junkies on YouTube to join us for future
fights or if you prefer to listen on
iTunes click the logo to download an
audio
[Music]
version